the Democrat system is telling him step
down and they can create all this new
energy and about who it's going to be
that they're telling him we're going to
find out if he actually is the nominee
because then that will be the inaccurate
I mean you know and I'm not bragging
some of you guys have dinner with high
power people talk to everybody too okay
we have dinner guys like you tell me
what I'm saying is this is directly from
inside the Trump camp at the highest
levels and directly from inside the
Democratic party so they they do not
want Biden they are seriously talking
about this of course as approval ratings
are in the doghouse he's 80 something
years old of course they don't want him
to run okay but he's making a decision
to run I mean he's not making any
decisions let's be honest well but it
shows that even though he is a vegetable
he wants power kind of like Yeltsin
didn't want to leave and it's the same
thing there's power struggles and power
struggles are dangerous the difference
is Boris Yeltsin was when his like early
60s at that point I want to say in in
Russia 1999 today we should only drink
three